the city is being pounded by russian
troops it has been turned into ukrainian
aleppo i think
even though the
the chemical weapons were not uh yet
used there by russians even though they
are they are threatening to do so uh but
the city is destroyed and the stronghold
of our marines and our volunteer
battalion
over there the remnants also of the
police policemen and
border guards are keeping together and
are giving it a serious fight the
problem is that we do not have enough
weaponry of the uh
medium middle to long range to
um to ensure that we are helping them
from the from the military standpoint to
besieged to to uh de-block the besieged
city of mariupol and that's the pain
that we have and we cannot get also the
the citizens out supposedly the corridor
had to work at this uh this afternoon i
haven't seen the reporting yet whether
uh citizens have been
able to get out because quite a few of
the humanitarian corridors have been
pre-agreed with russians but they have
been blowing up the cars
trying to evacuate or stopping the buses
with people and and sending them into
so-called filtration uh not allowing
them to leave
the mayor of mario paul estimates that
there are still around 100 000 civilians
still inside the city
in your mind is it a case of
not if but when mariopol is completely
taken over by russian forces now and
when that happens
what happens next
i think ukrainian troops and ukrainian
civilians there in mariupol have shown
the
heroic uh
capacity to to resist and uh heroic
capacity to survive we also know that
unfortunately quite a few of the
ukrainians from there have been
forcefully also deported from some of
those areas which already are taken over
in madhupur by the
by the russian federation and for us
it's a great
and important symbol of of our
uh resistance of our capacity to fight
back so i think none of the ukrainians
is is thinking of the
of the day or or the the time when
mariupol can be overtaken with um by
russian troops i also hope that maybe
some of those weaponry that is being
sent to us by the
uh foreign governments uh could be used
to to to help the city to be unblocked
yeah um your president president
zielinski renewed calls for more weapons
from the west pointing out that the u.s
has committed millions of dollars uh
worth of weapons for example just to
single out one country but um he said
they spent billions on weapons in the
war wars in afghanistan and you
mentioned aleppo in syria do you need
that level of investment to win because
your president said look
if we'd have had that kind of weaponry
we'd have won already
we have
finally got to the point when there is
no discussion whether offensive or
defensive weaponry uh
you know what is there for ukraine to be
sent finally i think the whole world
free world has understood that every
single piece of weaponry for ukraine
right now is of defensive nature because
we are defending our our state and our
nation for survival
so
definitely more and more urgently and
heavy weapons and long-range weapons
that's exactly what we need in order to
ensure that not only mario port but also
harkevis protected also the other cities
in the in the east of ukraine where the
assault is gaining momentum from the
russian federation where artillery
shellings are just continuously
ongoing during those
latest couple of days
understandably a lot of the focus is on
the east of your country where this
major offensive is this some 300 mile
front line but we were talking to one of
our correspondents who's based in odessa
at the moment and he was talking about
continued fighting in the south of your
country as well what can you tell us
about that where it is and what you
think the russian objective may be there
well the russian we have to understand
the tritium hall objective is
to erase our country from the map of the
world and that's what they are uh trying
to to reach by by attacking us from all
over because it's not only east it's not
only south as you've mentioned it's not
only a fearful fighting near odessa but
near the other cities like mikolai for
example in the in the south of ukraine
but also continued attacks and air
alerts
over other cities across the country in
the center in the in the west of the
country as well so russia is um trying
to
uh to secure
um its positions in order to pressure
ukraine to uh to agree to capitulation
to agree to its uh
absolutely illegitimate demands towards
the ukrainian authorities and
definitely we understand that our we
have the only choice either to survive
at the state and win
this war or um
capitulate and uh and not have the state
anymore and not have the ukrainian
nation so being deprived of the of our
right to existence so between these two
choices i think it's obvious what
ukrainians are
uh up to
yeah very much so um
the un refugee agency has said that more
than five million people have now fled
your country since the start of this
russian invasion within your country
millions of people displaced as well
because of the continuing fighting
russian the russian offensive
devastating lives and turning the lives
of millions completely upside down
how do you start as a country to to look
ahead to the future in terms of just the
it's not just the devastation of
buildings and cities and towns it's the
dismantling of lives is that something
that you can look ahead to yet or is it
hard to when you're right in the middle
of this
well it's definitely hard to look in the
future but definitely we are driven by
the desire to preserve this the country
to
preserve the nation and to ensure
that um if not 100 but then at least 95
to 98 percent of all those who have fled
the country from this brutal war that
russian terrorist state is
is is carrying out on our soil that they
will return back and that means
plans for rebuilding of the country but
also um i think also a lot will have to
be
a lot of trauma a psychological trauma
that we will have to be
dealing with and a lot of possibilities
that will have to be created for the for
the people to come back especially if
they're if their homes have been ruined
if especially if they have no place
where to return because of the of the
destruction uh here or because of the
destruction of infrastructure which
which will also take some time in order
to to repair it